mire el vídeo completo antes de inyectar
la insulina
es posible que su proveedor de atención
médica le recomienda utilizar una pluma
de insulina para la inyección a fin de
controlar el nivel de azúcar en sangre
la mayoría de las plumas vienen
precargadas con insulina y son
desechables cuando se acaba la insulina
puede desechar la pluma
algunas plumas son reutilizables y
vienen con un cartucho de insulina que
se carga en la pluma antes de usarla la
inyección de insulina con una pluma de
insulina implica seleccionar un área de
inyección preparar y llevar la pluma y
luego inyectar la insulina en su cuerpo
su proveedor de atención médica le
indicará lo siguiente qué tipo de
insulina necesita así como también
cuando debe inyectarse y qué cantidad
necesitará lo siguiente toallas
humedecidas en alcohol la pluma de
insulina una aguja nueva para cada
inyección
y un recipiente para desechar objetos
punzocortantes
una pluma de insulina pre cargada y
desechable tiene las siguientes piezas
una tapa de pluma
un recipiente de insulina
un indicador de dosis
una graduación de la dosis y un botón
para inyección
las agujas de la pluma de insulina
cuentan con una lengüeta de protección y
una tapa interior y exterior
asegúrese de seguir las instrucciones
que vienen con su pluma de insulina
cómo seleccionar el área de inyección
antes de inyectar la insulina seleccione
el área de inyección en el cuerpo las
áreas para la inyección de insulina
incluyen el abdomen o el vientre los
muslos los brazos y las nalgas
cuando seleccione el área de inyección
asegúrese de usar un área diferente cada
vez que realice la inyección
aplique la una distancia de al menos dos
centímetros y medio de la última área de
inyección y al menos cinco centímetros
del ombligo y seleccione un área que
esté a dos centímetros y medio o más de
cualquier cicatriz o lunar
cómo preparar la pluma de insulina
paso 1 lávese las manos con agua y jabón
y luego se que se las
paso 2 retire la tapa de la pluma de
insulina
paso 3 si es necesario mezclar la
insulina haga rodar suavemente la pluma
entre sus manos luego voltee la pluma de
arriba a abajo 10 veces
no sacuda la pluma ya que podrían
formarse burbujas en la insulina
antes de inyectar se revise la insulina
en la pluma para asegurarse de que sea
el tipo de insulina que le prescribió su
médico no ha superado la fecha de
vencimiento no está de colorada y la
insulina no contiene grumos
paso 4 use una toalla humedecida en
alcohol para limpiar el extremo de la
pluma donde se coloca la aguja paso 5
retire la lengüeta de la aguja
asegúrese de usar una aguja nueva cada
vez que se inyecta insulina
paso 6 con las tapas interior y exterior
de la aguja aún en su lugar coloque la
aguja en la pluma según las
instrucciones
retire la tapa interior y exterior de la
aguja
noto que la aguja me permita que entre
en contacto con ninguna superficie y no
use la aguja si está doblada una aguja
doblada puede bloquear la insulina o
evitar que salga
cómo llevar la pluma de insulina
al llevar la pluma de insulina se
reemplaza el aire en la aguja con
insulina y se elimina cualquier
obstrucción o bloqueo de este modo se
garantiza que reciba toda la insulina
que se inyectó
paso 1 encienda la graduación de la
dosis hasta que aparezcan dos dígitos en
el indicador de la dosis
paso 2 sostenga la pluma con la aguja
hacia arriba golpee levemente el extremo
de la pluma cerca de la aguja dos o tres
veces
paso 3 presione completamente el botón
para inyección hasta que aparezca una
gota de insulina en la punta de la aguja
es posible que tenga que repetir los
pasos 1 a 3 antes de ver aparecer la
insulina en la punta de la aguja si
necesita apoyar la pluma asegúrese de
que no entra en contacto con nada
como inyectar la insulina
paso 1 coloque la graduación de la dosis
en la cantidad de unidades de insulina
que necesita inyectarse
paso 2 limpie el área de inyección con
una toalla humedecida en alcohol realice
un movimiento circular para limpiar el
área de aproximadamente 5 cm de ancho
paso 3 si volvió a colocar la tapa
interior de la aguja de la pluma retire
la hora
paso 4 apriete un doblez de 5 cm de piel
en el área de inyección limpia
paso 5 introduzca rápidamente la aguja
de la pluma directamente en la piel en
un ángulo de 90 grados
asegúrese de que entre la aguja entera
en la piel
paso 6 presione completamente el botón
para inyección de la pluma hasta el tope
para inyectar la insulina en el tejido
adiposo debajo de la piel cuente
lentamente hasta 10 antes de retirar la
aguja para asegurarse de que se inyecte
toda la insulina
paso 7 quite la aguja de forma recta
para extraerla
paso 8 con cuidado coloque la tapa
exterior nuevamente en la aguja y luego
gire la aguja tapada para retirarla de
la pluma asegúrese de quitar la aguja
después de cada inyección
nunca guarde la pluma de insulina con la
aguja colocada
paso 9 deseche la aguja en el recipiente
para desechar objetos punzocortantes
nunca deseche las agujas directamente en
la basura
comuníquese con su proveedor de atención
médica si tiene preguntas sobre la
inyección de insulina o si el nivel de
azúcar en sangre permanece por encima o
por debajo del rango objetivo